I devote an entire chapter of the book
right before I end the book to privacy
and I do think that privacy is in pretty
great danger and as many others have
observed we tend to get used to it you
know the first people had to walk
through airport metal detectors it was a
most intrusive thing you can imagine and
now we find ourselves half disrobing and
not even giving it a second thought as
we walk through what strikes me most
though in 2008 is the ways in which are
the ways in which the invasions of
privacy around the corner are not coming
from the usual suspects they're not
coming from big corporations they're not
coming from government even though those
are the ones were used to respectively
gathering information about us so they
can target ads or give us credit or
government wanting to figure out who has
pot in the car or something instead I
see the threats coming from our fellow
citizens who have very cheap cameras and
their mobile phones or video recorders
or microphones teaching a class now I
have no idea if the class as it is
happening is being streamed onto the
internet for people to watch can easily
happen thanks to the wonderful
infrastructure we have a really cheap
sensors hooked up to great networks with
fast processors now posner as I
understand and as I've read from him he
basically sees privacy as a sort of
irrational desire anyway I suppose of
people have it he might end up
respecting it but what I've read he has
tended to favor the government having
pretty good license to snoop
particularly in anti-terrorism matters
and if it started to abuse that power
surely there'd be a whistleblower we all
find out and then there'd be a Watergate
I'm not nearly as sanguine as he that
that would happen so nicely every time a
government is empowered to snoop but
more important I think again the risks
are coming from the general public and
the database of pictures generated by
the world's
forests appearing in Flickr or facebook
facebook i think has over two and a half
billion photos in it right now those
will soon be sorted by exact location
down to the gps recording by timestamp
and by who's in the photograph facial
recognition technologies that make it
much easier to say who's in the photo
even if you don't know is the person
taking it and at that point i can start
asking questions like where was john
smith over the past two weeks where did
tourists manage to catch them on film or
show me everybody going in and out of
this Planned Parenthood clinic as the
photos reveal it that's a level of
privacy invasion that I don't think
we've hit yet and it causes trouble and
in chapter 9 I try to say more about how
we might take the sting
the solutions basically just as the
solutions in other parts of the book try
to look at that special quadrant in the
bottom left to say before we pass a law
that says what you're not allowed to
take pictures not allowed to identify
somebody in a picture you can take a
picture and identify them but you can't
use it for certain purposes there's all
sorts of drawbacks to trying to have the
government come in and attached a clamp
where we want to stop the flow of data
because it's invading privacy and I
think it's difficult for the firm to
help because the invasion is happening
down here as multiple people are taking
pictures in aggregating it so instead
I'm interested in solutions over here
and I think there are a couple examples
of community-based solutions that can
work early in the development of the web
people noticed that web search engines
were coming to life and they were
crawling the entire web indexing it and
then people go to the search engine and
asked what was where if you put
something on the web then it meant
generally it was going to get into that
index but what if you wanted to put
something up publicly so you can hand
out a link to it you'd prefer it not be
in Google you could try to sue google on
a theory of you're not allowed to crawl
my website or something but instead what
happened was a couple people got
together in formal unchartered and they
came up with a standard called
robots.txt robots.txt which you can find
if you go to most websites dub-dub-dub
website calm / robots.txt you'll see
instructions from the owner of the
website to robots like those of Google
saying you're allowed to go in this
directory and not in that one this is
not a legal assertion of right there's
not much law on this at all certainly
not in 1994 when it was invented instead
the idea is I'm just asking and here's
an easy way if you respect my wishes if
you want so it's balls in your court
Google if you wouldn't mind I know you
can get to this directory but here in a
very simple consistent way I've asked
you not to Google respects robots.txt so
does microsoft msn yahoo all the major
search engines respect it because
basically it's just the right thing to
do
and I would like to see a similar way of
packaging and we lay in a request about
our own privacy as what we would call
metadata to the data that expresses part
of our identity so if I'm in a photo I'd
like to be able to say all right clever
computer you've identified me as being
in that photo even as unbeknownst to the
photographer and I didn't realize the
picture was being taken but now that you
know who I am check this location to see
if I have expressed a preference for
photos taken of me in public have I said
please consult with me if you want to
use it have I said I don't care do
whatever you want have I said nothing
have I said I am a paranoid privacy
protecting person i'd really prefer that
you not use this photo in a very public
way if there were a way for me to just
express that view and have it associated
with data that bears especially on me it
puts the ball into the court of every
person who's going to touch that photo
later to make a decision as to whether
to contact me and whether to respect my
wishes I'm not sure they always would
i'm not sure they always should but to
have an internet that has a social
dimension as well as just the technical
dimension of here's a cool photo i'll
copy and paste it into my powerpoint
presentation because guy don't know who
these people are but it's a perfect
photo for what i want i think it would
be great to give people the opportunity
as they are remix 'uncle and putting
bits out onto the net and doing cool
things to have some sense of the
people's whose lives they're touching
when they do it and to have a moment to
connect with them and decide whether
they want to respect whatever wishes
they glean i think a chance to decide
what's ethical and whether to be ethical
could work in many many cases just as
robots.txt has worked in many but not
all cases to deflect a confrontation
that would otherwise